how's it going reject nation welcome to
our reaction
to zack snyder's justice league part six
epilogue
hoorah first things first i gotta
mention i'm going out of town this
sunday
i'm gonna be gone for about a week so if
anything big drops while i'm gone
please be understanding i'm out of town
tending to some personal business
secondly um i find it kind of funny that
i'm
showing you guys the ending reaction
moments of zack center justice league
yet we already did a four and a half
hour spoiler talk the other day here
live on the channel so
give it a listen when you get the chance
it was a whole lot of fun full length
watch along where you sync up with the
time code is over at our patreon page
for zack snyder's justice league cover a
whole bunch of tv shows a couple of
other movies as well over there thank
you to everyone who has been joining our
patreon page and lastly
got to thank eric over at nerdy chronic
for editing these reaction highlights
for us
i take a lot of work gotta work around a
lot of blocks but if it's public
that's what counts you did it buddy
thank you to
everyone for being here love this movie
hashtag restore the snyder verse let's
go
[Music]
the final part the end game
hi lois back to the dead
she loved it here
[Music]
snyder cut
you will give the people of earth an
ideal to strive towards
you will help them accomplish wonders
full character art
bring it right back to man of steel man
yeah right
we're just going through the kryptonian
ship reflecting the shot when he first
came into suit i love it
i love it i'm so proud of you
fly some hmm fly songs
stick to the plan that's why i brought
you together
me i did that i could never plan
oh he's getting his war machine i'm
gonna come back with a war machine
i'm gonna come back with a tank i gotta
go pick it up really quick
i couldn't fit it in with you guys then
yeah hell yeah
oh
that little punch in
oh dead
[Music]
oh
yes
yeah great that looks sand oh you agree
that looks
together yes yes yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and it's and they've earned their way to
that feeling like
oh
oh i love that sounds
oh
[Music]
victor fly
yes
oh yeah
ah
for dark side
oh
[Music]
didn't use freeze breath and the other
ones i think
did you just let it fall right on his
shoulder
that is so satisfying
everybody gets a turn
oh
music is so much better yes damn
oh damn oh we took off
no
i got the wind knocked out of me need a
few seconds that's all
[Music]
oh no oh no
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's too late
oh no oh my god what the hell's gonna
happen
ah
barry he's phasing through yeah
oh [ __ ] wow you gotta run faster you've
ever ran before dude
just gotta go faster than the speed of
light far beyond the speed of light you
gotta break the rule barrier
dad
[Music]
one of the best of the best
[Music]
yeah oh yeah he's doing it he's changing
things
yeah this is beautiful this is beautiful
yeah that is awesome that is
awesome
oh boy
there you go there you go
yeah wow
oh
this is great that's great i mean saving
a
russian
family would have been just as equally
just as cathartic
i'm not broken
wow
ew oh that is a terrible look
don't worry you can cosplay as hell boy
yes
take this back
[Music]
come on
he crushes it good job
this is like a live-action dc animated
movie i love it
get off our lawn
i told you
steppenwolf would fail we will use the
old ways
oh [ __ ] ugh
justice league too
looking more possible than ever before
wanted to fly
that's beautiful epilogue
six chairs right there
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
beautiful absolutely beautiful
[Music]
absolutely beautiful got a group of
people in the front of the
beams of light there the time
is now
oh whoa oh buddy
oh buddy i feel a nightmare coming on
who have you ever loved
it i can think of one person
he knows exactly what it's like to lose
so many loves
be very careful with the next thing you
say
like in adoption
how many can die in your arms before you
ground them to death
that's not very careful i'm your best
friend
besides who's gonna give you a reach
around
why you sent a boy wonder
i will [ __ ] kill you
oh [ __ ] oh no huh
oh no
no
[Music]
come on come on yeah
can i help you i've realized i have a
stake in this world
and it's time i started fighting for it
it looks so good i know
well we can definitely use the help so
i think it's pretty cool
i think you just might after this
yeah cheerleaders seem as good yeah
really good
[ __ ] who'da thunk marshmallow
grape
leto he almost reminded me of like jim
carrey
for some reason the way he's talking or
autumn
for autumn or autumn
it feels like two hours not as well
well the credits are rolling credits are
rolling
right now four hours later that was a
surprisingly
quick four hours absolutely
comfortlessly enjoyable four hours
it's i can never ever ever go back to
the other
cut
world's better the action was incredible
and like the
just the build up by the time you get to
the finale moments you're like they're a
real
team you really feel like they care
about each other earns
everybody there's still like plenty of
surprises uh you know we all know jared
little's gonna be in this movie uh his
his his time in the movie you're like oh
yeah i was better than any time
suicide is fun we're literally just
doing this as the credits are rolling
right now
i loved it i really i mean it i i loved
it like that time just flew by
literally we're being we're being
recorded on the
camera right now i cried like twice
yeah yeah i cried i cried like twice i
cheered a few times like this this movie
is is well i mean it's four hours long
it's well paid but do you know what it
is
every scene felt necessary every scene
felt purposeful
yeah you know it's like a different tone
than bvs or man of steel
and building on those tones still the
same way
helms deep is kind of the the most dark
nasty chapter of a trilogy like bvs kind
of is for this and then yeah just
that is definitely here but mixed with
oh
so much triumph this movie is well worth
it if you've been
thinking that this isn't going to be a
different movie
you were so wrong
more than just like there's scenes in
context that is completely absent from
the
um other version even the scenes when
uh you're like okay yeah that's in the
other cut
they're either expanded upon or you know
the color is different
but they're either way that's always
recontextualized
in a way that makes it better like every
scene
that you might have seen kind of in the
other one
like i said it's either longer plays out
differently
and just with all the additional context
the
scenes just work that much better like
there's
i can't really think of something i
didn't like in this
like this is all pretty damn great
really i mean
if you zoom in you're like well there
are a few expositional info dumps but
like of course but we need that
if we're going to see what the scenes we
got them that's like that's
in my mind right now like what can i
compare uh yeah
i think there's plenty of surprises in
here and there's plenty of
um great scenes and like everyone is
just
so much cooler and so much more badass
to quote aquaman
everyone is so much more fleshed out i'm
telling you by the time you get to the
finale you're like
i really feel like these guys care about
each other there's some great
quieter scenes between the two of them
between like two characters just
interacting with each other yeah it
takes time for those
to actually build not only the league in
its physical
you know fighting the the circumstances
form but also as
people together you know facing
insurmountable odds every journey feels
like incredibly personal yeah everyone's
journey feels personal
and yeah the visual effects are just
dynamite dude
the dynamite the music the sound designs
and i keep forgetting like zack snyder i
think he shot this himself and like it
it looks
amazing from uh i think though the
reshoot scenes he definitely shot
himself too yeah
the lighting the cam like the lens like
everything is
exquisite i mean i just love the tone
and you feel like a real
harrowing build throughout that by the
time you're getting to the finale
moments you do feel like
the league is uniting you know and that
you feel like there's real peril and
like steppenwolf is so much better in
this
like he's a real character with a real
purpose and
like this desperation and the you know
it's like it's definitely more violent
there's a couple of moments i was like
whoa that's that's right it's raider r
yeah there's a couple of moments like
that and a couple of f-bombs here are
there but the um
the violence like it packs a punch like
the
the action is just so much more fleshed
out yeah these are all quick thoughts
um you know i know we're not sounding
the most concise right now but
i do guys say like this one
just yeah justice league too yeah get on
it
start demanding that jake justice league
it gave me everything like a lot of what
we talked about in the trailers it gave
me everything i wanted there was a lot
that wasn't ruined or spoiled for me
and um when it makes the vision of at
least zack snyder's three films very
clear
from man of steel to now yeah a hundred
percent clear as a complete
trilogy yeah it's cyborg really is the
heart of the story
i cared a [ __ ] ton about like i cared
about everyone everyone
everyone i thought was necessary and
great yes it's more serious every
character is more serious than the other
version
but they never lose their personality
like there's still
so much personality in this film and
every
triumphant moment feels earned the peril
feels
real this is this is like i am so
this is worth it guys this is worth it
yeah
yeah it is a transformed experience from
what you've seen before
oh god it's so good yeah so good holy
crap
i think what we'll have to do is like do
a spoiler talk i think that's what we'll
have to do is like do a spoiler
discussion
maybe do a live stream one because this
is going to take a while to edit
you know this is going to take a while
to edit so yeah maybe thursday or friday
we'll do like a live stream spoiler talk
you guys just throw in questions and
stuff and we just have some fun because
yeah this is going to take
it is going to figure out
what format to put this all yeah and
then start editing it all so hopefully
yeah the full length will be up on
on patreon but then maybe we'll put that
up early but the reaction highlights
hopefully we can get that visible here
on youtube this is revealed in the
vanity fair article
uh when it says for autumn at the end of
the movie i mean that's just
that's what this is all about i just
hope zach zader knows like
people will be satisfied with this this
is amazing and
uh yeah absolutely for autumn this is
this is
[ __ ] beautiful i'm not
bullshitting you i didn't expect to cry
crying actually
i was i was really my heart was warmed
up so much
i was excited i was nervous i was uh my
heart was industrious
it's a little bit tough there's a lot
there's a lot of emotions
a lot of emotions man this is a really
this is a damn good experience sit down
with it
if you can commit to four to five hours
if you need to take break i totally get
it but
do it do it seriously what you were
hoping watch this one
and and i feel like i do i do think even
if you're you weren't maybe weren't the
biggest fan
of man of steel or bvs this is still
it still feels very different than those
ones i would i would definitely give it
a watch
i would definitely give it a watch like
this is this is a really awesome movie
um i was what's playing right now
oh damn oh wait we gotta turn this off
this we gotta listen to this thank you
guys thank you
watch this all right guys well i mean i
feel like i said a lot during this crash
but
yeah i feel like we gotta do something a
little more special we gotta do like a
spoiler talk with
yeah saturday or something like that you
know we gotta do something
on top of the initial thoughts yeah yeah
do something normally we do like a
a forever breakdown post
um post reaction but you know we've been
sitting here for like four hours we
filmed for a few hours
you don't want to work for four hours
worth of videos we need to get
organized i mean i'm pretty sure
everything i said turned to the camera
when i was looking at you guys is
everything right there i'll just
intersplice that in there uh because
yeah right now this is um
[Music]
i'm very i'm very happy this one exists
this is like too
this is like a a perfect this is the
happiest this
universe has made me i think like like i
do feel the truth because you know i
mean like i don't think it's a mystery
that you have been
you know very much endeared toward these
films you know from an earlier point you
have more experience overall with the
canon generally but
yeah i mean as a person who you know is
a little more toward the outside this
this one me like completely over
you know and i didn't even i didn't come
in with any like cynicisms but
yeah this was a really a really
beautiful rework
you know and i kind of feel lucky it's
like for the terrible circumstances
that led to all this i'm kind of
grateful that we got the timeline where
now
this gets to happen because it does lend
an extra layer of catharsis to it you
know
it needs to be seen in this type of with
this level of breathing room yeah it
needs to be seen
in a four-hour version i mean like it
sounds like ridiculous when you
think about it like oh it needs to be a
four-hour version but but
that's the version that's best you know
it is i think zack snyder just as a
filmmaker and hey he's made some films
that work and that are very
much not four hours but i feel like he
is a filmmaker the further he gets into
his career who just
begs breathing room you know you think
about this movie it's not
overly complicated for its four hours
it's just that it has a lot of people to
invest in
well there's there's a lot of yeah
exactly there's a lot of characters to
hop around there's a lot of moods
a lot of different tones and you got to
be able to seamlessly build and cut
around to them so none of it feels like
jarring or out of place and it has to
build
and i think the only way you can do that
while setting up the backstory of
steppenwolf and darkseid
the whole history there we don't need to
do as much with maybe
um diana but because we already got her
solo movie or bruce but you also gotta
set up barry allen you gotta set up
cyborg you gotta
do all this setting up and then also
feel like it takes its time enough where
you can be emotionally wrapped up
in there whether it be through the
dialogue or interactions
or through the visual storytelling this
to me had a great balance
literally my only concern i had one
concern that i expressed to someone
of like do you have any worries about
what the snyder cup might be and i'm
like my only concern is that
it's four hours only because it's a bill
with obnoxious slo-mo throughout
like that i was my only concern is that
it would just be a bunch of slogans it's
a two-hour movie
it's a two-hour movie if you cut out
like half the slow but you know you put
everything at regular speed
but it wasn't like i was wrapped up in
this from beginning to end it's
been surprisingly easy the one thing i
dreaded about the experience was like i
don't really want to sit here for four
hours
like sitting here has been like not a
problem like it's so enjoyable if the
movie is dynamic enough and i've seen
a couple in my lifetime to to really
yeah transcend that run time it's a
beautiful thing and yeah this one did
not feel like you know i feel like we've
been here a while but you know it's an
epic i feel yeah it feels like a
particularly
uh uh packed two hours really to me like
sitting here i don't feel as fatigued as
i might you know even having watched a
longer feeling three-hour movie
well i cared about all the friendships i
cared a lot about
silas stone and victor stone i cared a
[ __ ] ton about victor
and diana even then other coach who
wasn't bad but
she's so cool here like she's so good i
thought
everyone while taking on a more serious
approach than what we saw in the last
cut
people still brought personality you
know it was like the great balance of
heavy drama with their portrayals but
everyone brought personality to it still
that was my one cynicism coming in is
like everything looks so much better and
then i
saw someone someone's like early quote
or review or something saying like you
know
it's you know just as action-packed and
just as badass and it's just as
funny and i was like i'm not really
expecting that but totally like
throughout it had
some of you know it had a couple of the
humor beats that we already saw but
i thought yeah everybody had a
personality the humor felt completely
natural coming from the characters and
everybody had a charming humorous moment
at some point
you know and they built up this thing
with like bruce is going i need to unite
this league i need to bring these people
together it's not about
me being the leader and me being the
shining star like i
really love when he's like all right i'm
gonna go in there you guys do this
like he wasn't even around for any of
that steppenwolf [ __ ] he's covering
everything yeah
exactly side coverage oh this is so
different because he's
literally like he's making it about
they're the essential ones
yeah they're the net like yeah i'm
leading and i'm bringing i'm doing the
recruiting but they're the essential
ones
who have to take care of the job and i
was like oh this just it just makes more
sense yeah
he just flows so much better he is the
director he's just like i'm gonna set
things up so that you all have what you
need
yeah i'm gonna make sure you're
supported and then you guys are gonna
take the ball and run with it
all that stuff with barry allen
discovering his powers and the most
perilous of moments what he could do
with time um like
his stuff with his father just made me
like tear up at the end
big time absolutely a lot of like the
loving
emotional stuff is what made me tear up
yeah yeah man nothing really
the sad stuff kind of didn't but the
loving stuff really did you know
victor and silas lois and clark yeah
there's so many yeah so many warm
moments and that was something that
struck me is that like
i have found i i really like man of
steel i've found especially
in as of the bbs ultimate edition a lot
of stuff that i really like about that
too
but both of them were somewhat lacking
to me a warmth that this movie brought
out and that feels appropriate for
especially like
the arc of superman becoming superman it
actually feels appropriate in hindsight
to have some of those cooler tones lead
up to something that does
actually deliver that warm thing and it
does build up
yeah and it does build up to like
superman coming back and it's crazy
because i saw the other one like two or
three times and then to be able to watch
this feel like scenes that are i've or
moments i've seen before
suddenly feel brand new well it's a
crazy feeling
yeah cause i there's a certain element
of like cynical mind when the
bvs theatrical cut ends i'm like of
course superman's coming back duh
and then watching this i i was like i
know he's gonna come back in the back of
my mind but i was so invested in
everything else that was going
on and then when they finally bring him
back it does feel like a thing they
really had to work at
and figure out and bring everyone
together to be able to do
yeah you know and so yeah it feels so
much more
moving and cathartic when he finally
comes back and also those scenes where
he's
greeting them for the first time and
things aren't going
really how anyone expected them to like
those were tense and scary and it
brought back a mystery
where i had already seen the images
and it made me yeah fully caught up in
some like that's
i think a really special thing about
this is when you can get fully caught up
to the point where like throughout this
reaction we kept going oh i completely
forgot
this thing we're all anticipating yeah
like that's the mark of something that
is really
you know firing on all cylinders and and
focusing on just telling the good story
you know ah the peril felt real
the music is exceptional every moment
yes and everything felt earned i just
bought into it all
okay yeah this is gonna be quick
thoughts i think maybe it'll be fun
it'll be fun to do like a live stream
spoiler i would love that actually
like a live stream spoiler talk and just
take questions then that'd be the best
review for
our filming i think so what do you guys
want to hear about
yeah yeah um all right guys look hats
off
we're gonna like normally we talk for
like 30 to 40 minutes post a reaction
but yeah i mean
we filmed a lot earlier today it's just
fresh viewing
but yeah we're going to do like but i
mean i feel like the spoiler talk will
be out before this video is even out
for the many months it will take to
assemble i'm actually like this is
coming out tomorrow but this is
this is gonna be coming out like two
weeks or like a week or two from now
at least a week because it takes a while
so i'll be like minimum yeah it'd be fun
to uh
yeah i'll do a quick video quick little
video and then we'll do a spoiler talk
with people and just let them know don't
worry the reaction's coming yeah
man i don't know very satisfied
customers right now
yeah this is this is beautiful yeah this
was absolutely beautiful zack snyder
should absolutely be proud
for autumn that was beautiful all right
guys
well thanks for being here we'll talk to
you soon